lexandre langlois un policier il est
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie
alexandre langlois merci est d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
vous comprenez cette inquiétude qu'on a
entendu tout l'après-midi un article de
loi jugée liberticide qui inquiète
quel est votre regard vous sur sur ce
cette loi justement le regarde nous nous
sommes contre cette loi depuis le début
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle les policiers quand ils
sont filmés et que c'est dans le but de
leur nuire sur les réseaux sociaux sur
n'importe quel autre support les gens
risquent des peines de prison de deux à
cinq ans de prison
aujourd'hui la nouvelle loi propose un
an donc c'est moins bien
donc à partir du moment où c'est moins
bien en ce sens moins en sécurité en
tant que policier et deuxièmement petite
ironie du sort si on veut nous protéger
il faudrait limiter le nombre de
manifestations dans le pays
et pour ça faudrait pas faire des lois
qui mettent tout le monde dans la rue
comme aujourd'hui mes collègues avait
d'autres choses à faire ce samedi que de
venir s'occuper d'une manifestation
si jamais le parlement faisait un
travail un petit peu en adéquation avec
les attentes du peuple justement entre
la liberté d'informer et la protection
des forces de l'ordre est ce qu'un autre
équilibre aurait pu être trouvée selon
vous par des clips cette jeune appliquer
les lois existantes tout simplement
c'est que paul ans c'est des gens
mettent des images dans le but de nuire
aux policiers de l'été physique ou
mentale il risque deux à cinq ans de
prison ces lois ne sont quasiment jamais
appliqué aujourd'hui monsieur darmanin
fait de la communication pour dire
demain ce sera un an de prison
mais c'est ridicule appliquons ce qui
existe déjà comme ça y'a pas de soucis
sur la liberté de la presse pour
protéger les policiers les lois existent
elles ne sont juste pas appliquer de
demain celle là ne sera pas plus
impliqué que les autres on est dans de
la communication à bas niveau quand un
gouvernement ne veut pas agir il fait
une loi pénale parce qu'il ya personne
qui aura vérifié ce qu'il ya derrière
donc on laisse en l'état des choses ça
aurait été très bien
et deuxièmement cette espèce d'articles
est un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce que cette loi ne se limite pas
qu'à ça et à la casse complète de la
police nationale vers les polices
municipales et la sécurité privée
il ya beaucoup de choses dans cette loi
qui sont tout aussi graves que ce droit
à l'image et pourquoi justement c'est
tout aussi grave cette question des
polices de la police municipale ou alors
deux
du recours massif à la sécurité privée
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
lorsque la police municipale c'est un
débat politique ça reste des
fonctionnaires dont un moment attachés à
l'intérêt général par contre la
difficulté ce sera qu'en fonction des
communes et des budgets des communes la
sécurité ne sera pas la même surtout sur
le territoire ce qui n'est pas très en
adéquation avec la constitution et par
contre avec les c'est que la boîte de
sécurité privée le sérieux problème
c'est que une boîte de sécurité privée
n'a pas pour but l'intérêt général mais
elle de faire de l'argent et fait de
l'argent mais du coup à jusqu'à quel
point ils seront prêts à faire des
actions qui ne sont pas forcément légal
pour permettre à leurs sociétés de
gagner plus ou moins plus d'argent donc
là ça va c'est un risque et une dérive
assez grave car ils ont des pouvoirs de
police judiciaire notamment au niveau de
certaines contraventions on vient
d'entendre avec six poulains dire que
finalement cette loi elle va servir
elle pourrait servir à rendre invisibles
la répression face à la colère qui
pourrait y avoir dans les mois qui
viennent qu'est ce que vous en pensez
si on prend cette loi ça permet d'éviter
les affaires benalla je m'explique il y
aura plusieurs choses on a eu par
exemple la sphère benhaddad dans lequel
notre syndicat est partie civile parce
que ça entaché l'image de la police
nationale d'avoir des personnes privées
qui tabasse des manifestants il ya c'est
inadmissible et ça a été couvert par
l'elysée demain s'il ya peu le droit de
filmer les policiers qui nous dira si
c'est vraiment des vrais policiers et
pas des gens qui sont déguisés en
policiers pour faire un travail de
miliciens ou 1.2 dans cette loi
également l'utilisation généralisée des
drones pour filmer qui on veut avec
aucun cadre de contrôle derrière ondes
il faudrait faire comme ça n'y a pas de
sanction dans la sphère benalla
également l'elysée
avec monsieur emilien et d'autres
conseillers se sont servis des vidéos
pour des protections de
vidéosurveillance de paris pour essayer
de disculper alexandre ménard et vincent
crasse à l'époque donc pareil même chose
et dernier point ils sont en train de
vendre la police nationale à des boîtes
de sécurité privée qui était le projet
de monsieur macron sur sa sécurité à
l'elysée qui a toujours été assurée sous
la vème république par des gendarmes et
des policiers sont qu'aucun président ne
se fassent assassiner
il voulait mettre des gens de la
sécurité privée donc cette loi est un
résumé de la sphère benalla pour pu que
les gens comme les bena soit inquiété
pour qu'ils puissent est légalisée en
voir dans les missions de la police au
privé et pour paraître d utilisation de
vidéos sans aucun contrôle pour des
situations très particulières comme on
l'avait fait l'elysée à l'époque
donc c'est effectivement
matic on l'a déjà vécu sauf que demain
avec cette loi tout cela ne serait plus
possible à dénoncer et sur le terrain
vos collègues
est ce qu'ils sont réellement vers
angers par le fait des dettes films x
soit par des journalistes ou même parler
des citoyens deux choses il ya ceux qui
sont dérangés parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
commettent des actions parfaitement
illégal donc ceux là bas et j'ai envie
de dire tant pis pour eux cette veille
des brèdes poursuivis et condamnés
après il ya ce que la loi ne fait pas
d'ailleurs ce qui est une part eglantins
manquements dans cette loi c'est que des
fois les gens veulent nous filmer trop
près la loi aurait pu dire par exemple
on n'a pas le droit de filmer un
policier à moins de 1 mais 2 m ou 3
mètres pour nous permettre d'intervenir
en toute sécurité
après il ya toute façon les gens qui
veulent intervenir trop près d'une
opération de police c'est interdit par
la loi ils peuvent se faire interpeller
donc serai avec eux et de cadrer pour
éviter les débats sur la voie publique
donc effectivement cette loi c'est pas
le fait d'être filmé pour certains si
certains sont gênés parce qu'ils
commettent des exactions
d'autres sont gênés dans leurs méthodes
de travail et pour ceux qui sont sur des
missions discrètes ou secrètes comme les
renseignements ou certaines missions de
police judiciaire
ces missions n'ont déjà pas le droit
d'être filmé mes collègues sont cagoulés
donc je veux dire cette loi ne sert à
rien après 10 opérationnel pour la
police pendant entendu un des
témoignages de participants à cette
manifestation on a entendu les mots
dictature autoritarisme comment est ce
que vous vous recevez ces mots soit en
tant que policier
malheureusement en l'air soit sur
quelque chose qui peut s'avérer vrai
parce que notre syndicat avait combattu
à l'époque le nouveau code est
d'anthologie de la police nationale en
2014 qui a été promulguée par valls et
la majorité des syndicats de policiers
malheureusement est dedans nous ne
sommes plus défenseurs des institutions
de la république juste que c'était le
cas jusqu'en 2014 se passe et défenseurs
des institutions et des lois
et comme on peut le constater
aujourd'hui on met ce qu'on veut dans
des lois alors qu'une république on voit
que c'est un team de régime
donc ça change vraiment la donne et
avant nous étions défenseurs des
libertés individuelles jusqu'en 2014
depuis le 1er janvier 2014 les policiers
et gendarmes sont défenseurs des
institutions sans préciser le type de
régime et des intérêts nationaux qui
définit les interationale des intérêts
nationaux
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit des fois
compatible avec l'intérêt général nokia
tous ceux des glissements sur
l'utilisation de la police qui
effectivement pose question et m'ont
pris également sur les termes
avant nous étions des gardiens de la
paix mais on nous appelle régulièrement
des forces de l'ordre mais le
gouvernement de monsieur macro pour ses
campagnes de recrutement parle de
gardiens de notre paix mais c'est à dire
que c'est plus la pêche générale c'est
l'appel d'une partie de la population et
toutes ces dérives sont annoncés au fur
et à mesure et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on continue sur cette pente
dangereuse pour la démocratie et la
république
alors est ce que il n'ya pas à un risque
dans vu minh man un peu plus entre les
policiers et les citoyens notamment
avait avec cette loi
vinci effectivement parce que ce
qu'avait dit louis blanc seulement au
19e siècle il avait dit que normalement
le le bulletin de vote permet de
pacifier le débat public parce que
justement c'est un consensus qui se
dessine par rapport aux représentants du
peuple
aujourd'hui les représentants du peuple
enfin tout le reste c'est comme ça
qu'ils sont appelés bas fond des choses
qui ne font pas consensus qui fait qu'il
ya des manifestations et les policiers
sont occupés dans ce dossier en grande
majorité en surnombre sur ces
manifestations ce qui fait qu'à d'autres
missions que nous ne pouvons pas assurer
si le parlement assurer quelque chose de
consensus national qui était réellement
représentatifs du peuple
les policiers ne seraient pas déployés
aussi massivement sur toutes ces
manifestations nous pourrions avoir des
week-ends moins d'heures supplémentaires
et nous concentrer sur l'essentiel de
nos tâches
donc effectivement c'est à sète une
grosse crainte est un gros risque et en
plus sur cette loi sur cet article 24 le
réel problème c'est que de danser du
subjectif et de l'arbitraire se dire que
qui s'est interdit de filmer un policier
si on veut lui nuire par la suite mais
qui peut savoir qui va lui revenir par
la suite on ne peut pas savoir faire une
boule de cristal en aidant minorité
reporte dans des mauvaises film de
science-fiction nasonia la réalité donc
à partir de là sur le terrain ça va
compliquer les relations
police-population police journalistes et
tout ça pas finalement les pots cassés
vont être payés par des blessés de
chaque côté et je tenais à préciser que
monsieur darmanin qui dit que cette loi
par exemple il ya des cieux des
politiques qui va grâce à ckoi avons pu
se suicider ou pas être en dépression à
cause de ce qu'ils subissent sur les
réseaux sociaux
moi je pense que c'était abject de sa
part de se servir du système des
policiers qui se suicident en grande
majorité parce que et une perte de sens
de notre métier et un management
délétères à l'intérieur et que sa seule
réponse a été un numéro vert donc
monsieur damato jack dans l'utilisation
de la mort de nos collègues parce que
justement sa propre administration nous
pousse au suicide
merci beaucoup alexandre langlois
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir en direct
sur rt france pour revenir sur ces
manifestations contre la loi sécurité
global je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat vigiles